après les quatre années de l'agent russe
donald trump à la maison blanche
la russie fait finalement face à un
président américain élu sans la main du
kremlin
joe biden rencontre où vladimir poutine
afin d'empêcher le monde de descendre
dans le chaos d'une énième guerre froide
ou chaude puis à chez peugeot où je
crois que pendant la guerre froide
en tout cas la tension était très grave
et plus d'une fois il ya eu des
situations de crise aussi risqué
importante mais il y avait un respect
mutuel qui à mon avis ne fait défaut
c'est chose du côté des américains la
vision qu'ils ont de la russie n'est pas
rose non plus nous constatons également
en relation avec les nouvelles capacités
stratégie militaire que la russie a
développé pour défier nos alliances et
ça fait l'ordre fondé sur des règles qui
assurent notre sécurité collective
il s'agit notamment de l'agression de
moscou dans l'est de l'ukraine de son
accumulation de force d'exercices à
grande échelle ainsi que des actes
d'intimidation en mer baltique et en mer
noire en méditerranée orientale et dans
le grand nord de la modernisation de ses
capacités nucléaires et de l'utilisation
d'armes chimiques contre ceux qui la
critiquent sur le territoire de l'otan
la deuxième catégorie est constituée de
menaces non militaire et manon de bon
nombre de ces mêmes pays de tactique
technologiques économiques et
médiatiques qui menace notre sécurité
il s'agit ici de campagne de
désinformation et de la militarisation
de la corruption afin d'alimenter la
méfiance envers notre démocratie ainsi
que de cyberattaques qui disent nos
infrastructures les plus importantes et
vole la propriété intellectuelle à
droite difficile de compter tous les
dossiers où les points de vue russe et
américain divergent de l'ukraine à la
sphère navale n'est en passant par le
moyen orient la guerre vaccinale est le
gazoduc north stream 2 justement après
des saluts de sanctions ce dernier
dossier a été laissée tranquille
une fois le sommet entre les deux chefs
d'état décidé mais même si la rhétorique
du président en mairie
est devenu plus conciliante est lui bien
sûr impossible de prononcer des
déclarations sans les parsemer de
menaces nous ne cherchons pas le conflit
avec la russie
nous souhaitons avoir des relations
stables et ridicule une responsabilité
énorme combat nos deux pays
si notamment celle d'assurer la
stabilité stratégique et de maintenir
des accords en matière de maîtrise des
armes
je prends cette responsabilité au
sérieux mais j'ai clairement indiqué que
les états unis répondraient de manière
ferme et significatif si le gouvernement
russe était impliqué dans des activités
nuisibles
la russie elle ne s'attend pas en baiser
à la brejnev à l'échec du sommet
plusieurs bail d'un an chez nos
objectifs politiques
le président biden est un homme très
expérimenté je la fais de la politique
toute sa vie c'est un homme expérimenté
et je l'espère où elle n'a très pondéré
et méticuleux je note positive des
jeunes
j'espère fortement que notre rencontre
se déroulera de manière positive
je ne m'attends pas à une percée dans
les relations russo américaines
un résultat époustouflant 4 maintenant
ce n'est le fait que nous nous
rencontrions que nous parlions des
possibilités de rétablissement des
relations bilatérales que nous parlions
de questions qui revêtent un intérêt
mutuel et d'ailleurs il existe beaucoup
de questions de ce type c'est déjà pas
mal en soi est au jeu ça manque aussi
bien ni pour après les années folles de
la présidence trucks qui a vu notamment
le retrait des états unis de l'accord
sur le nucléaire iranien et la
dénonciation du traité sur le
désarmement nucléaire
inf les calibres maintenue jusqu'ici par
les deux superpuissances semble plus
fragile que jamais